[Musik]
es gibt da ein Szenario das da momentan
wohl alle gerne sehen würden den Sturz
von Vladimir Putin der Zusammenbruch
seines gesamten Regimes das ist
schließlich einer der Gründe für das
umfangreiche sanktionsprogramm des
bestens die russischen Eliten sollen
sich gegen ihren Führer in keine
auflehnen wir sprechen von einer
isolationskampagne die weit über den
Handel hinausgeht das Ziel ist es das
Herz aller Russen zu erreichen nehmen
wir ein konkretes Beispiel vor vier
Jahren war die Russische Föderation
Gastgeber der Fußballweltmeisterschaft
aber an der Meisterschaft in Katar
dürfen sie noch nicht einmal teilnehmen
aber auch Putin selbst beginnt zu sehr
mit den Gefühlen seines Volkes zu
spielen sind euch das hier an und jetzt
mobil machen für die Boot der Russen
Proteste und Gewalt um euch einen
Eindruck zu verschaffen dort folgt haben
einen ersten zwei Wochen nach der
Ankündigung der Mobilisierung mehr als
700.000 Russen das Land verlassen können
wir diesen Zahlen und es ist tatsächlich
relativ einfach auch die geflohenen
Russen zu zählen wir müssen nur die
Zahlen auf addieren die von den
Gastländern angegeben wurden natürlich
kann es trotzdem so Fehlern kommen und
die Vermutung dass Hunderttausende von
jungen Russen vor den werben der Armee
fliehen erscheint nicht weit hergeholt
schließlich haben wir auch alle Arten
von Straßenprotesten und Beschwerden im
Internet gesehen überlegt mal es ist
eine Sache einen Krieg zu unterstützen
den man im Fernsehen sieht und der von
der entsprechenden Propaganda begleitet
wird eine ganz andere Sache ist ist ein
Krieg zu unterstützen indem man selbst
an der Front kämpfen und vielleicht
sterben soll
[Musik]
mit der Tann Mobilisierung hat Putin
einen stillschweigenden
Gesellschaftsvertrag gebrochen indem er
sich verpflichtet hat das Volk von
seinem Krieg fernzuhalten und es ist ja
nicht so als wäre dies das erste Mal
dass dies in Russland passiert wenn wir
uns ein wenig mit der Geschichte
befassen werden wir sehen das Russland
vor der Invasion der Ukraine zwei großen
Mobilisierung durchgeführt hat eine im
Zweiten Weltkrieg und eine den ersten
weltkriegt während des Zweiten
Weltkriegs war fast allen großen klar
dass sie kämpfen mussten schließlich
waren sie von Nazi Deutschland
überfallen worden und die Deutschen
hätten sie im Fall eine Niederlage alle
fast klar und ausgerottet die
Mobilisierung im Ersten Weltkrieg endete
für den Zahlen hingegen sehr schlecht
denn in diesem Fall brach einen
militärische Meuterei aus eine Mutter
die der Schlüssel zum Schluss des Zaren
und zum Aufstieg der deutschen Biber ja
ihr habt richtig gehört dem heutigen
Video sehen wir uns im Detail an was
1917 in Russland geschah und stellen uns
im Anschluss die Frage was haben das
Russland der Zahlen und Putin Russland
gemeinsam könnte der Krieg in der
Ukraine zu einem Zusammenbruch Teams
führen ist so wie er die Revolution von
1917 ausgelöst hat heute lernen wir hier
auf visualpolitik all diese Fragen
beantworten und dazu zunächst einen
Blick in die Geschichte werfen bevor wir
aber damit loslegen müssen wir noch kurz
Werbung machen für unseren tollen
Sponsor für offshark auf geht's denn
surfst ist ein wirklich empfehlenswertes
und sicheres VPN welches zum Beispiel
keinerlei verbindungsdatenmittlung
natürlich kann ein Virtual Private
Networks VPN einen nicht vor allen
gefahrenschützen die in das lauern man
muss nach wie vor unsichtbalken lassen
und wissen was man tut aber es stellt
hier für einen Werkzeug mit gleich
mehreren Vorteilen da zum einen
erschwert ist im Kombination mit anderen
Vorkehrungen eure Aktionen messen
nachzuverfolgen und abzuhören mit Hilfe
verschiedener Sicherheitsfeatures könnt
ihr eure Anonymität z.B mit dem
integrierten Team wird das alle Cookies
und vor weiterer Vorteil eines Problem
ist dass ihr so tun können als während
ihr an einem anderen Ort so könnt ihr
zum Beispiel auch Webseite
Internetdienste zugreifen in dem Land
nicht verfügbar werden oder im Urlaub
damit schlagt die Zensur und blocking
ein Schnäppchen Netflix und anderes
anbieten von Spaß nutzen oder deutsches
Internetfernsehen im Ausland gucken mit
surfshark kein Problem aber das ist noch
lange nicht alles damit nur einem
surfshark Konto könnt ihr wirklich alle
eure Endgeräte im VPN registrieren
Handys Notebooks oder sogar euren Smart
TV so und zum Weihnachtsfest hat zwar
ein besonderes Angebot für euch auf
Lager wenn ihr den Rabattcode politik.de
Angebot bekommt ihr von uns
85% obendrein die ersten drei Monate
gratis dazu gab es zu denn dieses
Angebot ist zeitlich limitiert den Link
findet ihr wie immer in der Beschreibung
unter diesem Video also nicht wie du es
besorgt euch damit auch gleichzeitig uns
finanziell unter die Arme und das könnte
übrigens auch direkt mit Hilfe des
Spenden links den ich euch ebenfalls in
die Beschreibung gepackt habe wir sind
euch für jede Unterstützung bei der
damit helfen uns in Zukunft noch mehr
und noch bessere Videos zu produziert so
und nun werden wir uns auch eine
Zeitreise begeben ins Ausland des Jahres
[Musik]
im Februar Revolution
nein ich habe keinen Fehler gemacht ich
habe gerade die Februarrevolution gesagt
und nicht Oktoberrevolution die wir alle
kennen denn es gab bereits eine erste
Revolutionen zahlreich ein gutes halbes
Jahr bevor die Kommunisten die Kontrolle
über das Land übernahm das erste Mal war
es zunächst eine liberale eine
bürgerliche Revolution und ihr fragt
euch vielleicht was genau damals
passiert ist also schauen wir uns an das
russische reicht euch liegt es zu Beginn
des 20 Jahrhunderts unruhige Zeiten
bereits im vorigen Jahrhundert hatten
mehrere Kriege deutlich gemacht dass man
mit den westlichen Nationen und auch mit
Japan nicht mehr mithalten konnte in
praktisch allen Bereichen von der
staatlichen Organisation über
Bildungsstrukturen bis hin zu Wirtschaft
insgesamt war Russland heilungs veraltet
es gab verschiedene
Modernisierungsversuche die aber
besonders nach der Ermordung des Zahlen
Alexanders zweiten oft nur zögerlich und
die kleinen Schritten erfolgen seinen
Nachfolge Alexander der dritte
maßgeblich zu der alten Formel zurück
die die Romanows 3 Jahrhunderte lang
verwendet haben einer bewerten Mischung
aus Orthodoxie Autokratie und
Nationalismus das heißt die klassische
Ideologie des terroristischen russ
damals die auf der Loyalität zur
Regierung der Roman auf Dynastie dem
traditionellen religiösen Glauben und
der Verherrlichung des Mutterlandes
beruhte
Alexander III ging in gewisser Weise
sogar noch über die alte Doktrin hinaus
in dem er begann ausgefeiltere
Unterdrückungsmechanismen und eine neue
Geheimpolizei einzuführen die arana
parallel dazu führte er allerdings auch
kleines soziale und vor allem
wirtschaftliche Reformen durch Russland
begann sich allmählich zu
industrialisieren wenn auch viel
langsamer als die Staaten in Westeuropa
insbesondere dankmaschinen und Geschütze
wollte man endlich nicht mehr aus
England importieren müssen mit der
Industrialisierung verbesserte sich die
Lage der einfachen Leute allerdings kaum
es kam zu einer großen Land Flucht und
einer starken Organisierung obwohl die
Regierung den entgegenzuwirken versuchte
die er vor wenigen Jahren aus der
leibigenschaft entlassen und stark
verarmte Landbevölkerung strömt in die
Städte in der Hoffnung auf Arbeit in den
neuen verbringen großes Land entstanden
in denen sich ein neuer vierter stand
der Arbeiterschaft entwickelte mit denen
die russische Regierung nicht umgehen
konnte auf Alexander den dritten vierte
sension Nikolaus der zweite der sich
nicht wesentlich besser anstellte als
ein Vater im Gegenteil er führte
zunächst einen Krieg gegen Japan der zu
einer der größten historischen
benötigungen Russlands führte die
Unzufriedenheit mit den verlorenen Krieg
und die sich zuspitzende Lage unter den
einfachen Leuten löste die Revolution
von 1905 aus in dieser musste der Zar
einiges symbolische Zugeständnisse
machen wie zum Beispiel die Gründung der
Duma in der Parlamentarischen
Versammlung die jedoch wenig Macht besaß
später 1914 wurde er zum Verteidiger des
serbischen Nationalismus und verwickelte
Russland dadurch in den großen Krieg den
Ersten Weltkrieg Russland stand in
diesem Krieg Deutschland und Österreich
Ungarn gegenüber trotz anfänglicher
Siege über die Mittelmächte er lebt die
russische Armee ab 1915 empfindlich in
Niederlagen gegen Deutschland und musste
sich weit ins Mutterland zurückziehen es
gelangt Ihnen die folgt nach dem großen
Rückzug zu nichts zu stabilisieren und
zwar Nikolaus Beschluss persönlich die
Leitung der Truppen an der Front zu
übernehmen 1916 konnte er mit der
proziloch Offensive zunächst einige
Erfolge verkaufen doch die Opferzahl
erwiesen sich als zu hoch als dass die
neue Position lange haltbar gewesen wäre
es folgte eine neue Serie von
Niederlagen dass er 1917 begann in
Russland mit einem sogar für die
dortigen Verhältnisse sehr kalten Winter
besonders in der Hauptstadt Sankt
Petersburg oder Petrograd wie sie damals
siehst mussten sich Arbeiter entscheiden
ob Sie lieber erfrieren oder lieber
versuchen wollten sich warm genug zu
halten um den Hungertod zu riskieren in
ein Ei kostet viermal so viel wie 1914
und Butter 5 Mal so viel zusätzlich zu
der Lebensmittelknappheit und der
extremen Armut waren 1,7 millionenlosen
im Krieg gestorben weitere 5 Millionen
waren verwundet 1,5 Billionen waren
gefangen genommen worden und ebenso
viele Waren aus der Armee der sortiert
die Proteste hielten an und wurden immer
zahlreicher und nein wir reden hier
nicht von der Bursche Revolution wir
sprechen von der Revolution die Monate
zuvor stattgefunden hat das war keine
kommunistische Revolution sondern eine
deutlich liberale eine bürgerliche
Revolution
nichts versuchte der Zabi schon 195 die
wollte mit Gewalt niederzuschlagen doch
anders als 1905 waren die meisten
Soldaten nun an der Front und die Paare
tot und Reservisten die noch zur
Verfügung standen hatten wenig Lust auf
ihre Freunde und Land zu schießen einige
der Soldaten ignorierten Liebe viele
Lieder zarten davon sendete andere
schlossen sich sogar den Aufständischen
an zuletzt lief sogar die Blume über und
Nikolaus der zweite musste abdanken
zunächst mal nicht geplant das zarendum
vollständig abzuschaffen es wurde
lediglich eine Art interregelung
ausgerufen währenddessen ersetzt eine
professurische Regierung das alte
Kabinett des Zahlen diese
Übergangsregierung beschlossen Russland
Teilnahme im Ersten Weltkrieg
vorzusetzen und dabei die
internationalen Bündnisse respektieren
in dieser Nikolaus das Land eingebunden
hatte allerdings war diese provisorische
Regierung sehr schwach und das war ihr
großes Problem während sozialistische
revolutionäre wie zum Beispiel Wiki im
Petra das so wird immer stärker geworden
dass sie sich die Übergangsregierung aus
dem iranischen Politikern gemäßigten
Sozialisten und sozialen revolutionären
die Alexander karinski zusammen mit der
waldkrieg und Marineminister wurde an
der Spitze der Armee spielte karinski
ein riskantes alles oder nicht spielt er
blies zu einem verzweifelten Angriff um
eine Niederlage im Krieg zu vermeiden
und wie genau spielte sich diese
Offensive ab und das werden wir genau
ansehen
die keranski-offensive
[Musik]
russland hatte sich verpflichtet
gemeinsam mit sein Verbündeten ein
Offensive zu starten um die Ressourcen
des deutschen und österreichischen
ungarischen Feindes an zwei Fronten zu
binden aber die russische Armee war noch
mehreren Jahren Krieg nicht mehr in
ihrer Bestform Disziplin und Moral waren
nach der Abteilung des Tages stark
gesunken die Truppen hatten aufgrund der
immensen Verlust das Vertrauen in Ihre
Kommentare verloren außerdem hat er die
hohe Zahl angefallenen zwei grundlegende
Folgen für Russland 1 Soldaten immer
noch hauptsächlich bäuerliche Herkunft
aber unter den letzten Wert wichtigen
von 1916 waren nun auch Männer im Alter
zweitens und das ist noch wichtiger
wurden die neuen Rekruten mit weniger
Ausbildung an die Front geschickt als
ihre Vorgänger sie waren also nichts als
Kanonenfutter und kommt euch diese
Geschichte irgendwie bekannt vor ganz
genau wir sagen jetzt nicht dass sich
die Geschichte wiederholt aber es ist
klar das ist eine Reihe von Parallelen
gibt auch die heutige Regierung russland
hat keinen Respekt vor dem Leben ihrer
Soldaten der britische
geheimnisprognostiziert das Putins neue
Truppen in der Ukraine schwer leiden
werden da sie im Grunde keine Ausbildung
Erfolg haben im Jahr 1917 wirkte sich
diese mangelnde Vorbereitung auch auf
die Offiziere aus insbesondere auf die
unteren Ränge die höheren Offiziere
waren sich dessen bewusst und
beschwerten sich über die mangelnden
Fähigkeiten der neuen Unteroffiziere und
die allgemein schlechte Qualität der
ausgehobenen Verstärkung aber sie hatten
ein noch größeres Problem
die Neuankömmlinge an der Front waren
gegen den Krieg und gingen davon aus
dass das Scheitern der karenzki
Offensive die professorische Regierung
zu vollbringen und dazu dienen würde den
Frieden schneller zu erreichen und es
ist möglich dass viele russische
Soldaten in der Ukraine heute ähnlich
denken die Propaganda diskrimin hat den
eine Marsch in die Ukraine als
Militäroperation zur Bekämpfung des
Faschismus im Nachbarland verkauft die
Russen sehen die Intervention in der
Ukraine eher als etwas das nichts mit
ihrem Alltag in ihrem eigenen Land zu
tun hat zu Beginn des 20 Jahrhundert
betrachteten viele Russen den Ersten
Weltkrieg auch nicht als existenzielle
Frage und das ist etwas was das Russland
bezahlen und Putin Russland gemeinsam
haben das Fehlen einer klaren
existenziellen Ideologie bei der Führung
des Landes es ist klar dass die Ukraine
darum kämpfen als Land und Volk zu
überleben sie wollen unabhängig sein
oder demokratisches politisches System
haben nach europäischen Vorbild aber
wofür kämpfen die Russen anders als du
Zeiten der Sowjetunion hat der Kreml
heute keine so klare Ideologie wie den
Kommunismus mit anderen Worten die
Sowjets wollten ihre Situation unter den
Schlagworten geschichtlicher
Materialismus Antikapitalismus und
Antiimperialismus in jeden Winkel der
Erde tragen der putinismus hat jedoch
keine solchen internationalen
Bestrebungen Putins Ansatz ist rein
nationalistisch er basiert auf der Idee
dass es im Leben nichts Besseres gäbe
als Beruf zu sein diese romantische
Vorstellung von Nationalismus hat lange
Tradition und wurde schon von den Zaren
ausgenutzt im 21 Jahrhundert ist das
jedoch nicht genug Motivation um die
Bürger dazu zu bringen an die Frauen zu
gehen und noch weniger wenn man sich die
Bedingungen anzieht die der Kreml sein
Soldaten zumutet Wut über russische
Wehrpflichtige die ohne Ausbildung oder
Ausrüstung in die Schlacht geworfen
werden die karinski Offensive scheiterte
als die Österreicher Verstärkung durch
deutsche Truppen erhielten und die
russischen Soldaten heißt der satierten
teils Mutter Titten und sich schlicht
weigerten weiter zu kämpfen diese
Ungehorsam gab dem Deutschen Reich Zeit
seine eigene Frau zu verstärken und eine
gegen Offensive zu starten anstatt die
Moral der russischen Stärken bewies die
Offensive dass die Moral der Truppen auf
den Tiefpunkt war und sich keiner der
Brille darauf verlassen konnte dass die
Soldaten unter seinem Kommando die ihnen
Erkalten Befehle ausführen würden
[Musik]
die russische Übergangsregierung wurde
derweil von Problemen an der Heimat von
überwältigt nicht zuletzt von einer
genialen Idee des deutschen Feindes denn
jemand in Berlin dachte sich wenn Linien
mit uns über den Frieden behandeln will
warum holen wir nicht auf seinem Exil in
der Schweiz und schicken ihn nach
Russland und wie ist bei uns auch
Politik heißt gesagt getan im April 1917
fand eine entscheidende Jahr historische
Zugreise statt Wladimir Linien reiste
von Zürich nach Petra er legte mehr als
3000 km zurück was mitten im Weltkrieg
ohne deutsche Hilfe unmöglich gewesen
wäre doch Berlins Ambitionen wurden bald
belohnt bei seiner Ankunft in St
Petersburg verkündete Linien die April
Thesen er versprache dass wenn die
deutsche Wiki an die Macht kämen
Russland aus den Krieg ausscheiden würde
das Land den Bauern und die macht den
Proletariat gehören würde es war die
Zeit es historisches Slogans alle macht
den und hier sehen wir welchen Einfluss
mit begabter Massen auf die Klavier
Linien haben kann er wusste genau was
die Russen hören wollten heute
allerdings fehlt der Opposition gegen
Putin ein Anführer ein Vorbild dass die
Unzufriedenheit der Russen mit dem Krieg
zu einer alternativen Vision Vereinen
würde und niemand scheint heute die
russische Opposition zu unterstützen
soweit sie denn noch überhaupt existiert
anders während des Ersten Weltkriegs
Eduard Bernstein ein deutscher Politiker
der als einer der Väter der
Sozialdemokratie gilt behauptete dass
die deutsche Regierung zwischen 1917 und
18 mit etwa 10 Millionen Dollar
finanziert habe um Ihnen bei der
Machtübernahme zu helfen aber auch wenn
die Lage im heutigen Russland von Putin
lange nicht so schlecht steht wie heißt
für Nikolaus den zweiten grundsätzlich
gilt heute konzentriert sich die
westliche Unterstützung darauf die
ukrainische Regierung unterstützen aber
die Unterstützung der russischen
Opposition war vor einem Jahrhundert
sehr effektiv könnte das eine Lehre für
heute sein wie haben die Bursche Wiki
damals die macht er ergriffen
die Oktoberrevolution
[Musik]
nach dem Scheitern der Offensive
versuchte die provisorische Regierung
oder der Führung von karenzki die Armee
zur organisieren indem sie generalkonie
Luft das Kommando übertrug dieser
general hatte genug von dem Chaos in dem
sich Russland befand und versuchte eine
militärdikator zu errichten so diesen
Zweck startete er einen
konterrevolutionären Staatsstreich der
jedoch scheiterte aber er scheiterte
nicht am Widerstand der Regierung zu
diesem Zeitpunkt eigentlich keine Macht
mehr hatte weil niemand an ihre
Autorität glaubte laufen stieß auf die
Service und grundsätzlich auf den
Widerstand der deutschen Wiki dieser
gescheiterte Putsch versteckte den
Ordner Notiz Verluste Offiziere in den
Augen der Truppen die sie als bloße
Vertreter eine autoritären macht sondern
die ist zu beenden Geist es bedeutet
auch die endgültige Unterstützung der
Bursche die jeder einzigen Partei mit
ernsthaften Macht willen und Chancen die
garantierten das ist keine Rückkehr zum
Terrorismus mehr geben würde die
deutsche Wiki forderten von der
Regierung der roten Garde
Bewegungsfreiheit zu gewähren es
handelte sich unbewaffnete
arbeiterkommandos die für den Erfolg der
Revolution entscheidend sein würden die
Bolschewiki versammelten die Arbeit und
Soldaten von Petrograd um die
provisorische Regierung zu stürzen unter
der Führung von Linien wurde eine neue
Exekutive Gebilde die die Kontrolle über
das Land übernahm und die Checker
gründete eine politisch und militärische
Geheimorganisation die jede abweichende
Meinung unterdrücken sollte außerdem
unterzeichneten sie wie versprochen ein
für Russland ungünstigen Friedensvertrag
mit den deutschen reichen übrigens für
die ukrainische Republik eine kurze Wege
Unabhängigkeit bedeutet
[Musik]
mit dem Triumph der Oktoberrevolution
begann eine sechsjährige Bürgerkrieg die
Rote Armee und die weiße Armee die alle
Feinde der bolschewistischen Revolution
umfasst der standen sich gegenüber der
Konflikt verwüstete das ganze Land und
gipfelte im Triumph der Sorge jetzt
unterlegen die Frage ist nun ob heute
die Voraussetzungen für eine Revolution
zum Sturz gegeben sind denn die
materielle Situation Russland ist
sicherlich noch um einiges von den
Zuständen zum Ende des Ersten Weltkriegs
entfernt außerdem stellt sich die Frage
wer ist jetzt der wichtigste Anführer
der antibiotin Opposition nun das ist
Alexa dabei doch anders als Linien zu
seiner Zeit sitzen sondern in einem
russischen Gefängnis es dürfte also
schwieriger sein ihn vom Besten aus zu
unterstützen trotzdem bewegen sich dabei
dies Verbündete weiter diese Nachricht
wurde Anfang Oktober von ibanischer Down
auf einer Wallis rechte Hand die sich
der seine befindet veröffentlicht
nach
Barbarossa
das Problem für Revolution ist dass sich
die Dinge Seiten sehr verändert haben
die Kontrolle über die Gesellschaft über
die Kommunikation von Dissidenten ist
viel größer als es vor einem Jahrhundert
möglich war außerdem sind die Menschen
in Russland materiell bisher noch viel
besser gestellt als 1917 die Kriegstoten
erreichen noch keine Millionenzahl
bisher sind keine hungere Wolken
ausgebrochen und die Inflation hält sich
in Grenzen und ein weiterer Vorteil
Putins ist dass er in den Augen der
russischen Bevölkerung nicht so
abgenutzt ist wie als die Romanos wobei
sich Putin auch noch von den Zaren etwas
abgeschaut hat das jetzt zu seinem
Vorteil gereicht Putin Popularität schon
immer auf der politischen Apathie des
Volkes ähnlich wie zu Zeiten des
Terrorismus Putin hat es geschafft dass
die Russen Glauben Politik sei eine
Sache Putins und seiner Freundin da der
russische Krieg in der Ukraine jedoch
bei weitem nicht so verläuft wie es der
Kreml erwartet hat bringt die
Unzufriedenheit Bewegungen hervor die
vor Monaten noch völlig unerwartet waren
welche sind das schauen wir uns jetzt
mal genauer an
[Musik]
die putinoffensive
der Kreml hat mir der teilmobilisierung
seinen Einsatz verdoppelt und wie ihr
euch sicher vorstellen könnt ist das
nicht umsonst zu haben denn wie jeder
vielleicht mit Ausnahme des
tschetschenischen tiktokers kadiro weiß
macht es im allgemeinen keinen besonders
großen Spaß an die Front zu gehen vor
allem ohne angemessene Vorbereitung
hinzu kommt das zu dem Zeitpunkt als die
Einberufung bekannt gegeben wurde
bereits 7 Monate Krieg vergangen waren
mehr als ein halbes Jahr in dem viele
gesehen haben wie ihre Landsleute
verbindet oder sogar in einem Sack
zurückkehren deshalb haben es einige
gewagt ihre Stimme gegen die Art und
Weise zu erheben wie die Mobilisierung
durchgeführt wird dies ist zum Beispiel
der Fall des Präsidenten der Republik
daristan die Republik dagistan ist eine
russische Region an der Grenze zu gehen
und Aserbaidschan am Ufer des Kaspischen
Meeres der gouverne dieser Region ist
der Mann den ihr hier sehen könnt Sergej
Mikro
ist beim besten Willen kein Putin Feind
er hat eine steile Militärkarriere
hinter sich und zwar hat er es geschafft
in einen hohen Rang in Putins
Nationalgarde aufzusteigen jetzt ist er
der höchste Autorität in dieser Region
Russlands aber hört euch mit diesen
Fakten im Hinterkopf an was er über die
rekrutierungsoffiziere der Streitkräfte
gesagt hat bei mir ist gerade
sondern
zurück nach Bremen
bestimmt
ist eine der ärmsten Regionen Russlands
außerdem hat es nur etwas mehr als 3
Millionen Einwohner Milli Kopf befürchte
dass viele dieser tausend Millionen
Menschen nicht zurückkehren und seine
Republik im Schnitt dadurch noch älter
wird aber wartet ab denn die
Unzufriedenheit mit der Art und Weise
wie wir uns Teil Mobilisierung
organisiert wurde geht weit über ein
anekdotisches Problem in Dagestan hinaus
es handelt sich um einen etablierten
Trend die ärmsten und am stärksten
marginalisierten Regionen Russland sind
diejenigen aus deren Bevölkerung das
meiste Kanonenfutter für die
Schlachtfelder der Ukraine rekrutiert
wird
Russlands ethnische Minderheiten
beklagen den Krieg in der Ukraine es
gibt leider viele unbekannte bezüglich
der russischen gefallenen denn in
Kriegen gehört die Transparenz weißt du
den ersten opfern aber es gibt
Untersuchungen die eindeutig darauf
hinweisen dass Soldaten aus den ärmsten
Regionen der Föderation wie boreazien
oder ganz zur Mongolei und da ist dann
selbst unter den russischen gefallenen
überproportional vertreten sind und auf
der anderen Seite sterben nur sehr
wenige junge Männer aus den großen
Hauptstädten des Landes in diesen Krieg
zweifellos ein kluger Schachzug Putins
der die Loyalität der Eliten bewahren
und ihn an der Macht halten soll denn
die Revolution des 20 Jahrhunderts
bereiteten sich von den Städten in die
Peripherie aus und nie umgekehrt kommen
aufgrund der Sanktionen oder des Kriege
selbst noch weitere wirtschaftliche
Probleme hinzufügen worüber übrigens
kürzlich auf unserem Schwester YouTube
Kanal visual economic ein Video
veröffentlicht haben so braut sich
sowohl ins Zentrum als auch vor allem an
den Rändern des pudienreichs gleich doch
etwas zusammen das natürlich nicht genau
so wie die Revolution von 1970 verlaufen
würde sondern eher von
Zentrifugalkräften bestimmt wäre diesmal
wird es also eher keine petrograda
Sowjets geben aber Mütterchen Russland
hüte dich davor die peripheren
Republiken zu verärgern
[Musik]
für Putin ist dies ein heikler Balance
sagt denn er weiß ganz genau dass auch
die Spannungen unter den russischen
Eliten momentan eskalieren ihm ist klar
dass die Lage ernst ist und dass er im
Falle einer Niederlage gegen Ukraine
abgesetzt oder zumindest Teil entmachtet
werden würde schließlich stellt er seine
Inkompetenz immer wieder unter Beweis
indem er ihn fatalerweise in die Armee
Operation selbst eingreift der Rückzug
aus Herr Sonnen war seine bisher größte
politische Peinlichkeit sie symbolisiert
aber auch ein allgemeinwandel in der
russischen Strategie die Generäle
wollten sich schon seit Wochen
zurückziehen weil sie wussten das ist
militärisch unmöglich war die Stadt zu
verteidigen aber Putin wollte das
politische Risiko und den damit
verbundenen Verlust an politischen
Punkten nicht eingehen und traf alle
Entscheidungen selbst er hat die Armee
dazu gezwungen auf verlorenen Posten
durchzuhalten der Kreis der engsten
Punkte vertrauten verfügt kaum über
Militär Expertise es handelt sich
überwiegend um Ex Geheimdienstler und
Ideologen nun mussten sie endlich der
Realität ins Auge sehen dass ich auch
ein Putin mal dem Rad der Militärs
beugen muss wenn man ein weiter
vermeiden wollte
der Rückzug aus herson verliebt denn
auch ungewohnt geordnet und gut
organisiert den kremläuten ist klar dass
sie gegen die Ukraine keinen glorreichen
Sieg mehr erregen können und dass die
beste Option etwas wäre dass sie noch
irgendwie als Sieg leben könnten wenn es
Russland zum Beispiel Gelände das
derzeit besetzte Gebiet zu halten und
die Ukraine von dort aus weiter zu
destabilisieren und so irgendwie die
Hoffnung aufrecht zu erhalten sie doch
noch irgendwie zurück in die russischen
Einflussbereich zu zwingen es ist
offensichtlich dass die Eliten mit der
aktuellen Situation nicht zufrieden sind
aber Sie können nichts dagegen
unternehmen es herrscht eine Atmosphäre
die gegen Ende der
Ära in den 1980er Jahren die normalen
Russen sind auch unzufrieden aber Sie
können auch nichts dagegen tun also
versuchen Sie es zu verdrängen
interessanterweise schauen sogar immer
weniger normale Russen Fernsehen
Nachrichten als ob sie nicht mehr wissen
wollten was vor sich geht zumindest im
inneren Kreis der Theologie gibt es
jedoch keine Rest in diese Leute
Arbeiten schon sehr lange für sie sind
von dem abhängig und würden ohne ihn
nicht überleben und es gibt viele
Geschäftsleute in Moskau die von Krieg
profitieren ein herausragendes Beispiel
ist die der Gründer der Söldnertruppe
Wagner aber wenn man ein bisschen
genauer hin sieht erkennt man doch
starke Machtkämpfe
der derzeitige Chef des FSB alexander
bodnikow ist 71 Jahre alt und offenbar
gesundheitlich angeschlagen deswegen
versuchen die Leute unter Ihnen nun ihre
eigene Position um jeden Preis zu
verbessern und wie bei allen im heutigen
Russland spielt der Krieg die Hauptrolle
denn er bestimmt immer mehr das
funktionierendes gesamten Staates und
immer mehr auch der Wirtschaft jeder
versucht zu beweisen dass er einen
Beitrag leisten kann und das gleiche
passiert im Militär denn
Verteidigungsminister sagen ist
eindeutig geschwächt und wurde zum
Sündenbock für alle militärischen
Misserfolge es ist offensichtlich das
ist zwischen unschuldigung kriselt und
wahrscheinlich wird es nächstes Jahr
einen Nachfolger für den
Verteidigungsminister geben und damit
auch einen neuen generalstoffchef der
Streitkräfte die russischen Generäle
darunter auch surowicon bloß dass sie
sich durch den militärische Erfolge
profitieren müssen damit sie bei der
kommenden schade nicht unter die Räder
geraten wenn Zoro wickeln in der Ukraine
erfolgreich ist wird er der neue Chef
sein aber das bedeutet wiederum dass die
generelle die es unter ihnen und ihre
eigenen Ambitionen hegen wollen dass er
scheitert es handelt sich um ein
klassisches Partnerin und sie alle
wissen dass es überall in Russland viele
mehrstöckige Gebäude mit vielen Fenstern
gibt unter den Eliten herrschen also
enorme Spannungen es entstehen gerade
unglaublich viele Risse die sich vom
Zentrum her ausbreiten jeder konkurriert
mit jedem anderen und jeder will
beweisen dass er der wichtigste ist das
russische System wurde absichtlich so
instabil gestaltet damit Putin alles
selbst entscheiden und die verschiedenen
Gruppen gegeneinander ausspielen konnte
das hat ihn an der Macht gehalten aber
in letzter Zeit hat er sich
zurückgezogen und nicht mehr viel
eingemischt so dass das System anfängt
sich selbst zu überfordern angesichts
der militärischen Misserfolge geht er
zur alten strategiest über immer dann
von der Bildfläche zu verschwinden wenn
es schlechte Nachrichten zu verkünden
gibt er gibt kaum eigene Anweisungen
sondern lässt seine Latein Vorschläge
unterbreiten dir dann annimmt oder
ablehnt die Verantwortung dafür aber
ihnen überlässt es handelt sich um eine
recht schlichte propaganda-masche damit
in die Menschen nur mit positiven
verbinden und wenn etwas schief geht
dann waren es eben immer die dummen
Untergebenen die seine klugen
Anweisungen nicht richtig umgesetzt
haben in Nazi dann kannte man dies unter
dem Spruch wenn das der Führer wüsste
[Musik]
aber das unkoordinierte Rattenrennen der
russischen Eliten stellt für die Ukraine
einen großen Vorteil dar auf dem
Schlachtfeld sollte eigentlich der
Kommandeur der russischen Streitkräfte
in der Ukraine Sergej solo Wiki alle
Fäden in der Hand haben die Realität
sieht aber ganz anders aus dort kämpfen
zum Beispiel auch die Wagner Söldner die
bringen unterstellt sind und
keine Befehle erteilen er muss ihn um
Hilfe bitten die nationalgarantie die
theoretisch unterstellt sein sollte
kämpft ebenfalls aber ihre Offiziere
wenden sich für wichtige Befehle an
ihren eigenen Chef Viktor solothoff der
in Moskau sitzt und die Tschechien
gehorchen natürlich niemand anderem als
ihren Boss langsam Karriere auf daher
kommt es immer wieder zu haarsträubenden
Situation bei denen sich die russischen
Einheiten weder gegenseitig unterstützen
noch sonst irgendwie koordiniert
Vorgehen alles ist viel komplizierter
und komplexer im Vergleich zu Ukraine
die ein sehr effektiven Führungsstil hat
die Vagina Truppen im doll und was
erleiden zum Beispiel bei bachmund große
Verluste aber sie versuchen die Stadt um
jeden Preis einzunehmen auch wenn das
aus Militär strategischer Sicht keinen
Sinn mehr macht das Ganze sinnloses
Gemetzel im Schre gewissen
weltkriegseinstiel die nur einem
einzigen Zweck damit Pre Goschen Putin
zeigen kann dass er es geschafft hat die
Russen führen in der Ukraine im Grunde
also mehrere Kriege parallel und sie
werden nun versuchen ihre Stellungen zu
halten um einen ukrainischen Vormarsch
zu verhindern deswegen bringen Sie
übrigens auch immer wieder Verhandlungen
über einen Waffenstillstand ins
politische Spiel
und dass sie bis zum Frühjahr 150.000
neue mobilisierte Reservisten
ausgebildet haben werden die jetzt vor
allem in Weißrussland trainiert siehe
unser Video hierzu und die Hoffnung dass
keine beruht eben darauf nach der
erfolgten Ausbildung wieder mit dem
Format beginnen zu können das alles
zeigt uns das Putin Wirklichkeit seine
Position verhärtet und hofft dass ein
lange kriegt im Kampfes will der Ukraine
und den Willen des bestens die Ukraine
zu unterstützen berechnet wird aber die
Ukraine werden nicht einfach abwarten im
Gegenteil sie werden alles in ihrer
Macht stehende tun um den Russen die
Situation zu erschweren und sie werden
auch ihre eigenen offensiven vorbereiten
schnell Erfolge lieber oder Person
sondern vielleicht schwierig sein aber
wie wir in unserem Video über die
ukrainischen Winter gesagt haben geht es
darum die absatzspirale für Russland
einfach weiter zu drehen hierzu gehört
ist die Feind immer wieder durch
unerwartete Stärke zu überrumpeln so wie
zum Beispiel neulich mit
Drohnenangriffen auf Flughäfen tief in
russischen Hinterland diese haben unter
den russischen Eliten für Entsetzen
gesorgt und das Pentagon hat noch mal
nachgelegt indem es Augenzwinkern
betonte die USA während der Ukraine bei
der Entwicklung Fähigkeiten so
Durchführung von langstreckenangriffen
nicht im Wege stehen
ein materieller personeller
wirtschaftlicher wie psychologische
abnutzungskrieg ob man vorderster oder
einer Heimat von vollzieht sich
scheibchenweise in kleinen Inkrementen
anschaulich ist dies auch an der sich
nach und nach ändernden Rhetorik der
krabbelgardisten zu erkennen und ihre in
sich zusammenschmelzenden Kriegsziele
guckt jetzt ziel war es ja ursprünglich
die nationale Identität der Ukraine
auszulöschen und sie in sein groß
russisches Reich einzulider als klar war
dass dies nicht mehr gelingen kann ging
es darum so viel territoren wie möglich
einzuleben und zu annektieren da ist nun
aber offensichtlich ist dass die
russischen Besatzer auch aus immer mehr
annektierten Gebieten zurückgedrängt
werden die die Ziele und Sinnsuche von
neuem los selbst immer mehr Teilnehmer
der berüchtigten Propaganda druckschuss
in russischen Fernsehen machen sich
augenscheinlich immer weniger Sorgen um
die Ukraine und immer mehr darum wie man
am besten mit dem Auseinanderbrechen der
Russischen Föderation umgehen sollte
daher jetzt meine Frage an euch glaubt
ihr das Putins verschiedene irgendwann
stürzen könnte Russland gar nicht
auseinanderbrechen oder vermutet ihr
eher dass seine Kontrolle über die
russische Gesellschaft zu groß ist und
eine Revolution keine Chance hat haltet
ihr es für möglich dass wir
Unabhängigkeitsbestrebungen in
gebeutelten Region sehen werden wie sie
es zum Beispiel der jüngsten Geschichte
in Tschetschenien gab wie immer sind auf
eure Diskussion zu diesem Thema schon
mächtig gespannt ich hoffe dass euch
dieses Video gefallen hat mir vielleicht
auch das dabei gelernt falls ja geht uns
bitte ein Like teils mit euren Freunden
und vergesst nicht das Abo mit Glöckchen
und keines unserer Videos mehr zu
verpassen natürlich freuen wir uns euch
jederzeit über eine Spende von euch mit
uns hält dieses Projekt weiterzuführen
den Link dazu findet ihr in der
Beschreibung unter dem Video mach's gut
und bis bald
[Musik]